TREATED AS A NEUTRAL PLATFORMS,
THEY MUST BE NEUTRAL PLATFORMS.
OTHERWISE THEY SHOULD GET THEIR
PART OF OUR EVENING FROM THEM
IMMEDIATELY.
THIS CONGRESSMAN IS PUSHING TO
DO THAT AND WE ARE GRATEFUL FOR
THAT.
THANKS SO MUCH FOR COMING ON.
WHY HASN’T THIS HAPPENED
ALREADY, THEY ARE VIOLATING THE
INTENT OF THE LAW.
>> BIG TECH BUYS OFF CONGRESS SO
THAT LOCAL TELEVISION STATIONS
DON’T ENJOY.
IF WE JUST WAIT AROUND, BIG TECH
WILL STEAL THIS ELECTION FROM
DONALD TRUMP AND THE AMERICAN
PEOPLE.
IN 2016 WE WON THREE RUST BELT
STATES BY A POINT EACH AND
THAT’S WHEN NO ONE THOUGHT
DONALD TRUMP COULD WIN.
WE HAVE TO BE AS AGGRESSIVE AS
THEY ARE.
THAT MEANS BILLS LIKE
SENATOR HAWLEY AND I HAVE FILED
TO CHANGE SECTION 2:30 IS
PUBLISHERS ARE NOT THE UNBIASED
PLATFORM THEY ARE, IT MEANS AN
EXECUTIVE ORDER BUT IT ALSO
MEANS GETTING THE OTHER ELEMENTS
OF THE GOVERNMENT TO ENFORCE
EXISTING LAW.
THE FEDERAL ELECTION COMMISSION
NEEDS TO GET OFF THEIR DUFF.
THAT WAS A HOAX.
WE HAVE DOMESTIC ELECTION
INTERFERENCE GOING ON RIGHT NOW
AND I WILL BE FILING A COMPLAINT
WITH THE FEDERAL ELECTION
COMMISSION RIGHT NOW BECAUSE OF
WHAT THEY’VE DONE TO
PRESIDENT TRUMP.
AS A VOTER I HAVE THE STANDING
TO DO IT AND PRESIDENT TRUMP
SHOULD CALL ON THE COMMISSION
QUESTIONS THAT ARE FOR THEM SO
THE TECH COMPANIES GET FLUSHED
OUT OF THE BUSHES.
>> Tucker: AND MARK ZUCKERBERG
ARGUES THAT YOU DON’T WANT TO
SEE THE SECTION 2:30 VOTE.
SO YOU PROBABLY DON’T WANT TO
CHANGE THAT BUT YOU HAVE TO MAKE
THESE COMPANIES LIVE UP TO THE
PROMISE THEY MADE.
HOW SHOULD YOU FORCE THEM TO DO
THAT?
>> BIG TECH COMPANIES HAVE A
TREMENDOUS AMOUNT OF INFLUENCE
OVER CONGRESS WHICH IS ONE
REASON WHY I DON’T TAKE THEIR
PAC MONEY OR ANYONE ELSE’S.
BUT ON THE QUESTION OF WHAT HAS
TO BE DONE, I AGREE WITH YOU.
IF SOMEONE IS GOING TO ASSERT
THAT THEY ARE ON NONBIASED
NEUTRAL PLATFORM WE SHOULD NOT
JUST TAKE THAT AS AN ARTICLE OF
FAITH.
WE HAVE TO HAVE INVESTIGATIVE
WORK DONE, TRANSPARENCY AND
DISCLOSURES.
IF WE ARE GIVING THESE FOLKS THE
PRIVILEGES THAT YOU WOULD GIVE A
PUBLIC UTILITY COMPANY THEN
MAYBE WE NEED TO START
REGULATING TECH LIKE THE PUBLIC
UTILITIES THAT THEY ARE.